guys it is dollar cost crypto manand DCC
Trap God that's right I've got someone
very special in the in the in the studio
with me I've got the CH God himself
Charlie cultivate crypto what's up man
hey how's it going it's all good we've
been streaming all day we've been uh
doing parties all weekend you know it's
just what we do just busy so well I've
got someone real special uh in the
studio today well I've got a lot I got
two special every everyone's so special
I'm a woman I'm the most
special oh here we go again here we go
again are you sure that
what so let's go to my favorite
colonizer uh
Pearl we got Pearl in the in the house
what's up thanks for having me no
problem the most special guest the most
special and all right and as well as
this this man's got a special place in
my heart no homo of course but uh very
special place in my heart because he is
the him and James Tusk are the last
Mohicans out here teaching Day game in
the whole man it is like boggling to me
right shout out to Troy Francis what's
up man good stuff man thanks for having
me no problem here yeah dude in the
[__] flesh Brother In the Flesh man
and get to meet charliie in person for
the first
time sh around I just want to be a part
of things you just landed here like an
hour ago right yeah I literally touched
down about an hour ago hour and a half
ago something like that you just got off
the flight yeah But for only for Miami
though oh okay that England I'm dead
after that no no no no
good stuff yeah Miami Florida yeah so
where I mean because I know you've been
flying all over the all over I mean
basically all over Europe and stuff like
what what have you been doing because I
I know you're like teaching I mean are
you teaching like day classes on Day
game or you doing night game what are
you doing right now so when I was in
Miami I was there I did a couple of
shows with people over there but mainly
I was there with with some clients and I
took them out and we were doing Day game
in Miami but we were also doing night
game so combination of the two cuz
obviously Miami you know great Party
City whatever so we went out we went out
in wiws we went out in Brickle little
bit on South Beach and it was it was
great actually it was a blast it was
really really good so are you so this is
important thing is like like one there's
like two big things right one you need
sales to make money and two um a lot of
people said like you shouldn't trust
somebody that doesn't know how to get
girls now I don't know when the girl
side maybe it's like you don't trust a
girl that can't do her
makeup dang it Pearl come on let me
know but um you know do you take people
that literally don't know anything and
or like or do you kind of like like they
have I know I know you have to they have
to they buy it and they have to call you
and say like and you have to know their
whole details and stuff like that I mean
what like are you is it most guys just
need like a push or like hey just go try
this like numbers game or what are you
doing to help them out well it's a
combination in terms of the kind of
people that get drawn to needing help
with this stuff there's kind of a
combination of people so some people are
just complete beginners they find it
very hard to be like socially adapt
they're you know they're sort of at
Ground Zero with it and then there's
other dudes who are actually very well
put together very well you know look
good maybe they're making some decent
money you know we've we've had a few I
mean i' I've taught this year several
crypto millionaires you know dudes who
made a a ton of cash so it's not like
it's not like the finances are a problem
and necessarily their looks or anything
but it's just there's something that's
getting in the way of them having those
interactions right with women that are
going to actually lead somewhere I have
a question can someone be like too ugly
to
[Music]
save
have you ever have you ever had someone
come to you and you're just like I I
can't like take your money like I can't
I mean we I see he saying my brother in
ch we we would try to we would seek to
be ethical because one of the um one of
the uh criticisms that dating coaches
get a lot on Twitter and stuff guys will
become oh you're just scamming inels you
you're ripping off insults W and I mean
we would seek to be ethical about it so
if somebody came and we literally
thought for some reason this dude is
just beyond help then we would have to
has that happened
genuinely genuinely no it hasn't
happened it's a lot of hesitations in
the I'm just trying to has it got like
no no I'm hesitating I'm only hesitating
because I'm trying to think like what
would I actually do would I actually
turn them away but no I mean seriously
we would like if you genuinely thought I
just can't help this dude then we would
say listen man you know you need to work
on some other stuff or maybe you should
okay go to Mexico and get some plastic
surgery or you know but no I mean
generally speaking this is 100% serious
the people that we get they're actually
it's not about the looks I'm not saying
looks don't count because obviously they
do but it's actually not their looks a
lot of the time they look either average
or sometimes a bit above average it's
not that it tends to be to be frank it
tends to be kind of autism that gets in
the way more more than anything or just
being too in their head you know exactly
exactly is it just saying the high or
something or it's like this is the whole
this is why we always preach so much
about sales like everyone even Zer we
just we had Zer we were talking to Zer
the other day it's all about even having
one year six months of sales and stuff
door too or phone calls code calls he
like could do sales yeah he did sales
for about a year he says he's like [__]
that [__] helped me out so much to two
years nice copers cop cop copy the UK no
they the US Milwaukee so I have a
question like what's you guys's best
like pickup line like like so okay so
you know I'm I'm chilling in my coffee
shop like what your best I want to hear
your opener oh I want to hear this [__]
I want to hear everyone's opener and I I
want to pick my favorite no no I don't
go with one lighters or anything like
that I'm not like that all that cheesy
or whatever but if I do okay right it'll
be after I have a conversation for a
while I want to know what's your first
word like what do I get oh it's just
like you know I just introduce myself
nothing you know crazy or whatever but
it depends on the situation I got to
read each situation okay so I'm I'm
sitting here what do I get like I want
to get like a first sentence a first
sentence
[Music]
I don't know I'd have to think about
that for a little while for you all
right it's dep on woman to answer your
question one thing I will say right is
once we get to once I have a
conversation with somebody get to know
them a little bit right if they're like
putting up a resistance all you need to
say is just say come
on that's
it pull with this [__] I've seen it I've
seen it that's the secret come on come
on come on let's go that's why that's
why that's why C pooke come on
all right what's my opener Mr Mr Day
game are you from Tennessee cuz you're
the only 10 I
see that is the gold I've saved you 10
grand you don't have to you don't have
to come on the boot camp now that's it
you get all the [__] you ever need open
what's your how do you open how do how
would I open all right I'd be
like hey what sign are you oo Scorpio I
could
never
see that's good that's actually good
that's hilarious that's actually good
because he's opened with what they used
sort of like what they used to call a
egg really a neg right which is like
you're sort of like you're going in
there you're showing initial interest
like Oh what now I want to know and then
you're like and then you're like well I
tell you what it is it's like it's
classic pushpull Theory which is what
they say you need to do so it's like you
sort of put hey so what's what sign of
you she's like it works every [__]
time because every like all women even
Pearl believes in astrology for some
reason
and it doesn't matter if they say it
doesn't matter what they say you're just
like they could be in cuz I'm in Aries
right they could be like an oh I can
never date a [__] Aries wom away and
then there I don't even believe in
zodiac signs but why you you do you not
believe in Zodiacs no I don't seriously
why you always dating
Killers um every
woman I think every woman I've ever
dated okay let's do the
opposite no but I'm just like
I I would just want to know why like
what's wrong with my side that's you
explain way it works exp but that's
that's the thing isn't it because most
guys are going to come and they're going
to s in some sort of way so it's going
to be like oh what side of you Scorpio
oh my God that's amazing like I'm this
and we're so we're so and they're going
to try to do things to convince you why
you guys should be together and what
he's doing is taking it away so he's
like no [__] that it gives me like like
a a gross feeling in my stomach when
like when they convince you like the
same thing we can't help it it just like
repulses what's the worst you've ever
heard oh that's a good one
actually or one of the worst I've never
heard anything that bad I don't think
well I mean it doesn't have to be add it
or maybe you just thought was like super
cring oh oh I got a marriage proposal on
a first date that's
what yeah this was a really interesting
cuz it's really interesting like I guess
like being well famous or I mean I
famous I don't know but like um because
it's like you'll go on a date and they
know everything about it's like not even
like it's different if I can equally
like research you do you then we're on
equal grounds like I can find out
everything about you and you can find
everything out about me but if it's just
onesided yeah so this guy asked me on a
date and I was like okay and yeah on the
first date he was like yeah I I know you
said that um like you this is what you
look for like on this podcast and you
don't need that much time to decide if
you want to marry someone so so yeah and
I was like w I'm eating my words right
now I was like I mean maybe I I need
more than like one day so that was
probably that was that was kind of it
was interesting though I was like I
never thought this would happen to me
like so then he said so how did he put
it like well he was just like well he
I'm trying to remember how he phrased it
it was like you know I
just I just it was at this cuz he wanted
to play basketball at a
park the first dat was that was that the
DI Yeah well yeah he flew in for this so
it was like H he was like trying to get
home court
advantage been playing it for
years yeah and so I'm trying to remember
how we said it but he was like yeah like
I think we could get married like I want
a lot of kids like Jes Christ yeah and I
was just like wow this is just like a
lot was it at least the end of the first
date or like right I we did I think we
played horse oh Jesus you guys actually
[__] played because he brought he
brought that well honestly I I'm a
baller so like if someone wants to play
basketball on a first day that's like a
perfect first date for me I know I you
could call me a low maintenance chick I
don't know but like I just I love
basketball she was just trying to break
his knees
[Laughter]
like yeah so that was probably like the
was he kind of was he kind of awkward
after that moment then or did you hey
chat chat I want I would say awkward he
was really not like I don't I don't I
feel a little bad telling the story cuz
he was really nice you know but it just
it was just like a lot away you know
just one you guys I like I want to work
for it a little put your best pickup
lines in the chat right now we'll read
them in a minute be really funny be
funny yeah but watch shout up like w
work would you put what about high on Pi
Morgan
yeah yeah yeah I don't know I'm a woman
I can't teach you how to fish or
whatever they say well yeah I mean there
is yeah I mean so in regards to the
dating thing because actually I was so I
met up with Zena when I was in Miami and
we were talking about I we shot a little
video actually and she was talking about
her ideal first date and she was saying
all this stuff like uh oh you know I
wanted to take me to an anime convention
or I wanted to take me to you know do
all this complicated stuff and that's
actually not what we recommend at all
what what we recommend is actually
keeping the first dat very simple which
is basically like just going for a
couple of drinks oh I was going to say
basketball no well no I wouldn't I mean
I I don't know man I mean maybe for you
maybe maybe it works but I personally I
reckon just go for a couple of drinks go
to a nice Lounge go to a bar sit down
have a couple of drinks get to know each
other probably that's probably a better
one and basically try don't ask her to
marry you and
basically basically try but if she says
no you can just say come on
yeah you know that might have
wor I don't recommend it the I don't
recommend it yeah
but yeah I think keep it simple just
just do that shoot your shot and then
you know say Hey listen I'm staying
nearby why don't we go chill see what
she says if she says no fine okay all
right then arrange another date but I
think keeping it simple in those early
stages because you don't want to make
too much investment I think that's one
thing you know guys taking women out for
dinner and all that stuff it's not
generally a good idea want to keep it
kind of lowkey and and if you're a high
value D I'm not saying this guy wasn't
high value but if you're a high value
dude like in inverted commas whatever
that means right are you really going to
have time to be doing all these like
crazy activities you know what I'm
saying like anybody who puts a lot of
money on the first day is just asking to
get taken advantage of I actually don't
like it because I don't I don't want
anyone to like expect any like I feel
like like I don't want anyone to expect
anything so do you feel the pressure of
that like do you feel like if a guy does
like like normally if he does like too
much early on where I'm just like I'm
trying to get to know you and see like I
don't want to feel like so so champagne
five kids and all this little much well
I was like you you could have started
with the second date before the proposal
I don't know but po what about when you
see those surveys where girls say that
they there's these surveys I've seen
that say that women will go out just to
get a free meal or something you know
like they're not actually intending to
to do and to me that sounds terrible
because what what you're saying like
does are they not thinking oh [__] now I
I kind of owe him something but secondly
why would you really want to go for
dinner with somebody that you're not
into they probably just don't give a
[__] you know what I
mean I I I don't think I would want to
go for dinner for 2 and a half hours
away or 2 hours with somebody that I was
just not pay for it you know yeah do you
know what I mean it's like weird but
they they're probably just broke you
know yeah this is such a good crypto
pickup line right here he's like my name
is salana can I crash at your place
tonight yeah crypto one liners I don't
know about the I don't know so few
females I have 32 ethereum works every
time
Nellyville stupid uh d T $20 can we give
this orange to pearly things yeah
there's some new shitcoin some some no
no thank you you know what's funny when
I did the Bitcoin video they gave me
like I don't know 500 bucks worth of
whatever the like mini whatever it is
yeah and I already lost the code so I
was like I was like thank you for your
donation I guess I was like well I'm
like not meant for this cuz I'll Just
Lose
It get you an easier option get one
where you don't have to actually keep
any codes just like a password you know
you usually do for your email or
something like that yeah there's way
yeah there's there's ways to do it and
stuff like we talked about this earlier
on Charlie show if you guys haven't
checked out go on Charlie show we
interviewed pearly things about all this
stuff but um you know the the stuff
about money and game and stuff like
because like guys either depending if if
guys are just someone you have a natural
a natural or like or a blue pilled
there's like blue pill ba no blue pilled
alphas and then then there's the red
pill Alpha and stuff like that later on
there's these Naturals these guys that
can easily get dates and stuff and that
and then then they start concentrating
on money and then guys are just they're
super bad but they're like [__] it let
me just try to get a lot of money and
stuff like obviously um everyone can
work on their game and stuff right but
but do you do you I mean in your
experience right do you find guys who
have game can get money more easier or
it's kind of like these money guys and
then you can transition them into game I
reckon if you're natur if you're a
natural in game you're going to be the
kind of person who's probably going to
make more money naturally right
um focus on it yeah because that that
sort of guy is going to be probably
somebody who's quite driven probably got
that more like a type personality you
know all of that kind of stuff it's
probably a bit more suited to the other
way around though and this is what guys
always think oh I just get a load of
money and then you know the women are
going to flock to me it doesn't really
it doesn't seem to me to really work
that way around at least not in any way
that you would want it to you might get
some gold diggers you know but as I say
we've talked yeah yeah exactly but yeah
exactly but I mean we've Tau plenty of
guys with a lot decent amounts of money
who aren't pulling a muscle but
basically so you know it's a bit of a
fallacy I don't know man I you know I
think guys just think are going to sit
in the VIP room with a bottle of
champagne and the women are going to FL
to me right right doesn't work like that
now have you been to a lot of
nightclubs okay I don't want to talk to
you anyway now i' say like um when I was
younger we go to bars but not like clubs
okay so what's the UK scene like
terrible
it's honesty I honestly could count I
don't even think I've been out five
times in the UK to like a club or
anything it's been busy like
Everything's changed a lot really fast I
mean your channel blew
up what are you like 1.5 million or
something. put some
respect round it up to
two not to talk [__] but yeah I don't
know um trying to even think I want I
can't see strobe lights I got I have
this thing called this like
photosensitive seizure disorder so like
you know if I see a strobe light you she
get like a seure yeah so I can't even go
to clubs I I don't even can't go to rap
concerts either country I went to a
country one the other day they were kind
of they're usually outside so it's okay
but like yeah if there's strobes I got
to go I can't damn that's kind of crazy
so like the re I mean the reason I was
kind of asking about like uh I mean I
mean that sort of thing and stuff is
just because like obviously I've talked
to Fresh about this and I've talked to
like Waller you know Kyle you know
Charlie and everyone I was talking to
the guys too is like these clubs and
stuff there's there's like a lot of
night game has been killed some of the
best night game is done in like actual
real bars versus actual like cuz some of
these clubs the way especially here in
Vegas and it's in happening in Miami
where like if you don't have a they've
made like an economic model where you
basically you don't have a table it's
hard for you to like like if you go to
Mr Jones right Mr Jones in Miami it's
all tables there's like no it's all
tables so like how you going to pick
anyone up unless so you're already like
spending tons of money so this is kind
of like they've made like the where the
club experience us should be just
there's a bar like two bars and then the
artist or the music and then you kind of
a semios pit and you can pick people up
that way right yeah yeah I think um the
best club that I went to in the last and
this was about a year ago now with Tusk
is it was in Colombia we went to this
club in bogatar in Columbia and it was
just there was no VIP there was you know
it was just a bunch of people dance
floor there was loads of different bars
and stuff like that that kind of thing
is good that's a bit more like the old
model you know where it wasn't this
segregated thing where you got the
Ballers over here and you know the
brokies over here or whatever it was
just everyone getting it you know and
that is is a good vibe but most clubs I
think are not very good for for game and
in London as well because in London
you've also got clubs with you know
super highend and you know you got to
buy a table and all this kind of stuff
and it it's just I think I mean I've
been out in Vegas before actually and if
you're not if you if you haven't got a
table you're sort of you're wandering
around the sort of the broky area aren't
you and I I don't know whether I mean
it's not that you can't pull cuz
obviously you can but it's a bit like
you're not you're not showing much value
Vegas like easy mode I don't really
think it is to be honest but it depends
I depends yeah if you get chicks that
are traveling here right they tend if
they're with the girls you know it's a
little bit different right but also I
mean it could go either way it can
either be like no we're only like
staying with the crew or you know start
the wedding parties the wedding party
it's the wedding parties it's the
easiest right yeah because like the
girls are all under because the their
friends getting married now they feel
like dog [__] because it's like oh [__]
I'm falling behind and then they trying
trying hook up have you have you ever
hooked up with a bride to be no no no no
I've got
more that is I mean that is inviting
like evil evil into your life have you
ever had a bride to be try to hook up
with
you I don't think I have let me I don't
think I have I I just heard horror
stories I hear a few of those no just
like I mean you just see him on like
Reddit and [__] I don't know if true
right right yeah I personally I was
talking to a client about this like
earlier in the week or last week um I
personally if somebody's married I'm
just like yeah okay whatever have a nice
life you know I'm not I'm not I'm not
interested in going there but I've got
friends who who do do that or I've had
friends in the past who do do that and
they've always said to me that the
married women are the easiest to get to
get with which is a pretty depressing
thing but you know but is and that's
I've also heard now this is I don't know
I'm not married but I've also heard it's
easier to pull when you are married too
cuz like the wedding ring cuz the
wedding ring why are you noding so hard
in the back
like ring in his back pocket like AR you
like 21 nobody
detected you could just you could just
save the hustle and buy a wedding ring
though couldn't you I mean yeah just go
out with my
ring go borrow one of your friends well
it's the old pre-election thing though
isn't it because presumably the women
think oh he's taken so therefore I don't
know very he powerful isn't it you know
can be yeah I mean I mean there's some
chicks that like will go Scout after
married guys they'll be like home
Breakers right yeah there are chicks
that that won't though as well cuz
they'll have that boundary of course
right and stuff like I wish we had
recorded what we were talking about in
in the studio earlier that [__] was
crazy it was funny that would have been
the best but I know
PE but um but yeah I mean that that's
kind of what I mean that's kind of
what's going on there right so this what
I'm talking about is like the game this
is why you know getting your money right
so important but it's not the only thing
but it's a very important thing because
like there's two modes guys go into
money mode and then they go into girl
mode and and so I it's very very rare
when I meet a guy that's that can get
their money and their thing and they're
and they're scaling it pretty decently
yeah that's right cuz I mean I wasted
most of my 20s in a you know pointless
uh you know promiscuous sort of haze of
you know nonsense and I mean I wouldn't
recomend and I'm still
going Chang Troy the part the party
Still rocking
but you're just miserable inside with
according to the Trad
G yeah no yeah yeah exactly no but um
what was I going to say um yeah I
wouldn't recommend guys do that I think
you know the money muscle muscles game
frame whatever thing is is is absolutely
100% true and I think in the manosphere
now it's much more promoted because back
in the day when I was you know when you
know when I was when I was like young
and innocent or whatever when the game
stuff started coming out it was it was
basically like right learn this thing
called game right don't bother about
value doesn't matter if you learn this
thing called game and you go and do it
you know go to the go to the club say
these lines do do these different
routines and stuff you'll get the goals
and then people realize well hang on a
minute that's nonsense you need to have
the value as well and that's why we've
had people like the Tates and Justin
Waller and you know all of these dudes
who are like no you you know you got to
get your moneyl Sterling yeah absolutely
yeah I think some people like it's like
the procrastination right they're like
oh I got to do this then I got to do
that then I got they don't want to
so they just keep saying they got to do
other [__] exactly and I totally agree
with the with the self-improvement
message I think it's 100% right yeah you
should but you should it has to be done
as you're on your way you can't just
like wait the chat's going bananas over
you Troy he's like why does Troy look 21
but he's in his 40s Troy found the
Fountain of
Youth it's the Fountain of Botox
actually yeah but um you've got but the
thing is right so guys will think right
okay so I've got to get the value yeah
I've got to get the money I've got to
get the muscles and all which is great
but if you're not practicing your RZ
then you're still going to be the DK in
the club you know what I'm saying cuz
when you think of all these guys when
you think about you think about Sterling
you think about the Tes you think about
Jay Waller they've all got they've all
something about them haven't they do you
know what I'm saying it's not yeah they
got the money they got the looks and
stuff but it's also they got that thing
you know and you got to have that thing
like an aura like an aura like they have
a presence exactly a presence and
whether it's like I know everyone this
is like kind of a Rollo thing along with
a couple other people from the red pill
but it's this whole thing of like you
have to dress in this outfit or you have
to have like you're dress you're
everyone's in a costume every we all
have these masks on and stuff like it's
like business mode party mode and stuff
like that right so they're really well
suit game versus like dressing like a
hip-hop gu it just all depends on what
you're going after like I mean like
fresh he like yeah yeah I mean I'm going
to this kind of Club I want to be
blinged the [__] out and [__] like a
boogie with the hoodie had the shiniest
diamond necklace I've ever seen in my
[__] life I'm so I'm so like
mesmerized by today but like it was like
imagine like but like um he's a good
dude actually and so we met him at the
the um rolling loud and stuff last year
but he had like the clear like I've
never seen diamonds like it it was like
like you would look at it and it would
like draw you in like I've seen a lot of
diamonds and like those [__] was crazy
so I don't know that's a big Tang but
like this one I'm talking about is so
it's kind of like I mean so what do you
tell guys depending like when guys are
coming up to you and stuff is like I
want this because are you just showing
them how to get up to girls or are you
showing them these the hey man this the
kind of girls I kind of want to go after
you give them advice and you probably
need to dress this way to get we style
as well actually and what we've done
just recently we filmed some content
with a tailor in London who I go to
James Tusk goes to him as well he's a
really good guy he's got like a you know
great great sort of setup over in London
and um this isn't a massive plug
necessarily but we're doing some
packages with that guy who could do
online consultations and stuff like that
because because getting your look right
and I can't talk cuz I've just jumped
off a plane basically but I mean
generally speaking getting your look
right that's that is super important but
again you know these are all all of
these things are great but if you don't
have and the Riz side of things or
whatever you want to call it is so
important it's so key and and that is
the key thing that guys guys kind of
need to learn you know speaking of
getting your look right I have a I have
a present for you oh thank
[Music]
you
all camera show the
camera hit hit pep for that shouldn't
vote I can I something that we W nothing
I don't even need your love you treat me
like a stranger and I feel
[Music]
so there we go hey and we're back I
should go on the strip tonight and see
how how fight no and whenever anyone
asks me and I'm like they're like oh
like why does it say that I'm like we
can't even pick boyfriends how the hell
are we supposed to pick the leader of
the Free World they love that just just
use that line exactly guys
idiot come on it's okay for you Pearl
right like you know I know you you blown
up and stuff like you by you still have
a lot of your like some friends and
stuff from back in the day and stuff
like are they asking you for like advice
in terms of because they see like I mean
you're you're running basically kind of
a dating Channel sort of like dating
advice and stuff channel are they asking
you for advice in terms of their stuff
um I'm trying to think friends back in
the day cuz I know you told me about the
volleyball team well I well I mean to be
fair a decent were feminists they
weren't like that happy with me well
sometimes when you you know become
really successful at something as well
people know you from before and so
they're like Le sometimes less likely to
be like oh you know I want that
information it's some you know it's it's
interesting because what we do you know
with our families and stuff is we teach
people about crypto but with as much we
as we know about crypto you would think
there would be other people you know
seeing how much we made and all that
stuff and be like I want to do that but
then they don't so they don't might not
have the right motivation either so you
know yeah no I mean to be honest it's
lonely when you get pretty big
especially with women it's like women
are ruthless oh my gosh but yeah I I
would say there's a couple but I don't
have like a ton of friends from back in
the day right did a l did people
distance themselves because of the M
well I I had one make a video about me
really oh yeah she totally did [__] yeah
it's like well how long was it was it
like it just like hit a yeah it was like
a Tik Tok oh yeah no but she was making
all these Tik toks I was kind of like
damn yeah my boy Izzy do Pearl surviv so
many cancellations sck a strong person
to get through that yeah I know that's
crazy all right so Pearl it's time to
get your canceled all right why
shouldn't tell me right now why should
PE why should people take away the abil
let's see why women shouldn't vote tell
me why oh because I figured out as the
root of all evil no seriously I when I
cuz I basically just started looking
well first okay the rabbit whole started
when I started reading the
anti-suffragist writings so there was
the suffragettes which they try to label
the suffragettes as like these
reasonable women that just wanted to
give Women rights gen ones gen ones yeah
they weren't they were terrorists they
they funded terrorist attacks they tried
to do assassinations like these were not
nice women and the anti-suffragists had
more support than the suffrages so the
anti-women voting and I was like well
why wouldn't they want to vote their
writings said this is the beginning of
them destroying the family unit you're
supposed to the Natural order of the
world is supposed to be God men women
you're supposed to submit to your
husband that is the only way things work
like in everything and I started to
realize like when women we are our
greatest selves like the mothers that
are actually like good wives good
Mothers like the men can't compete with
that you know it's like they're they're
it's like beautiful but it's like when
we go on our own it's chaos we become
[__] and like
and yeah and one out of 25 well yeah one
out of 25 women under 35 r on only fans
right 90% of us have been on birth
control the average body count is
between five and eight and all the men
say we're lying so we probably are and
and and I was like I was just reading
all these numbers like the more choice
that we get the worse we choose I'm like
we're just dummies and then I looked
into propaganda and I realized um in the
early 1900s they figured out prop like
what propaganda is and basically they
they they figured out you can show the
women some sad story of a 12-year-old
chick that can't get an abortion and we
just run to the polls we're like oh no
save the 12-year-old rape victim let me
run to the polls even though the men are
logical they're like that doesn't happen
often you know yeah but and so that
started in the
1900s and so then I was like huh why are
there all these policies that actively
discriminate against men like why are
there like why are they able to say
Andrew Tate's a human trafficker why can
I divorce rape a guy like why why don't
men get access to their kids and it's
because all none of the politicians can
get elected without pandering to women
so there's no incentive for anything to
change and when I figured this out I was
like we got to take that [__] away we've
gotten so out of pocket then I figured
out then I figured out I was like wait
we just live life on easy mode the only
reason any of us make money normally is
just cuz we're hot and young and I was
like um and all the industries we take
over like education healthc care suck
right whenever we get into management
biggest is in in nursing yeah whenever
we get into management they always just
fire us or we run the company into the
ground and I was like wait so literally
like men do 45% of men do infrastructure
jobs so that means Trucking I mean it's
an expanded definition a little bit but
we added in trucking we added in like
buses we added in plumbers like and so
it's like half of men are doing that
we're only 76% of women are and I'm like
how is it fair and we're a net taxpayer
loss so we spend more than we make so
I'm like wait the men are paying all the
money they're doing all the hard jobs
and as a thank you we discriminate
against I'm like we're out of pocket we
have been too spoiled we got to take
this [__] away
immediately and we're all the college
jet as well now yes men aren going to
college and they teach you in college to
meet two men I remember this cuz oh my
God they totally do they totally do they
totally in the UK too everywhere
everywhere well I I don't know I didn't
go to school here but but I've I've
heard women like like um use terms that
I don't know where else they would have
got from so like for example
sociological studies well well sociology
was like made up anyway it's like not
even real where they would psychology
but yeah I remember in College we would
go we had this like um thing that we
like I don't know what it was for I
think it was to play in sports like I
just remember I had to go to this
meeting and they basically were like if
you say no before sex and then like he
Bas basically the man's pushy all right
there guys are like car salesman please
buy the
car keep going with it you'll get
it this is getting better youever you
ever buy something and it's like you
really didn't want to buy it but the
salesman just wouldn't let it go
basically they said if a guy does that
it's rape and it's because they switched
they switched the and this is what women
do we go into these industries and then
we're like we don't like your tone and
let's change the meanings of words and
they take these words that have meant
the same thing for a hundred years like
what was rape it used to be I pulled a
chick off the side of the road and she
was screaming and crying forced
basically yeah forced and it was I
forgot the exact definition but it was
like forced carnal or or some other yeah
yeah but but it's basically for sex and
they switched it to sex without consent
but consent is subjective I met a guy
who literally thought he raped a chick
because like she was like grinding on
him or like like in bed and then she
said no and I was I don't know some
weird stuff but I'm like that's not the
same thing he was grinding on her or she
was grinding on him well she was like in
his bed and I I don't that but I was
like that's not the same thing as like
rape right well it also goes back to
like responsibility if you're in some
dude's bed what do you think y these
Zoomers are [__] and then and then
on top of that they added in more they
add in new words too they add in these
like new words that nobody knows what
they mean coercion yeah coercion
coercion sexual assault and and they
teach you this stuff in these like
classes did you guilty before being Prov
innocent well and women are dummies like
we're all idiots did you see that thing
P the UK they've they've Incorporated
love bombing into what can now be called
coercion so basically what is love
bombing he's being
nice
nice we ha nice guys so much we we ha no
America put them all in jail yeah yeah
and so I was just like this is all
craziness this is all but you're right
about zumas though cuz I I saw a stat I
think Chris Williamson posted a stat
earlier but it was it was something
ridiculous like it was something like
18% of effectively Zoomers think that
asking a woman out for a drink is always
harassment or something like that it was
it was just it was just these are Li it
has to be some beta
C people being behind a screen right
there's so much behind their phone and
everything that they're just like oh now
like [__] being a human is illegal I
know yeah it's women we're such dummies
like think about this we pick husbands
who you spend the next 50 years of your
life with probably the most important
decision we can make who we reproduce
with we pick off of horoscope
signs horoscope signs totally legit I
swear this is our decision making I mean
they call it
horoscope and I'm just like okay should
we be should we trust us so now let me
get this straight the politicians have
to ask the women who don't pay the
majority of the taxes who don't do the
majority of the work they have to cater
to us and what we want when this is our
track record of decision making we've
had more decisions to make in 100 years
and we've chosen to be
[__] wh and I'm like okay so and we're
going to say they get to pick who gets
the nuke
button it's almost like you would you
would elect someone or get someone out
of office because they say mean words
and put someone with dementia in you
know I'm not
gonna yes so that's why women
women should not you're a Biden guy
no I was like I was I was like I'd have
to
[Laughter]
disassociate dis and then I forget about
it two minutes
later but um yeah it's it's God damn
dude that's it's so I mean all there's
so much bad [__] going on but at the
same time too it's also these evil
people at top as well there's it's these
1ers of 1centers at the top that allowed
this pharmacology it's like just to
allow I mean they allowed like they I
mean it's not the it's not the scientist
fault that they created the the Plan B
pill and they created the you know the
um what's it called the birth control
pill it's these evil agencies within
either the government or within like you
know these whatever these one world
order people that pushed out this [__]
during the 60s and the 50s and the 7s
and stuff to be out there everywhere
plan and D Plan B used to you know what
plan B really was originally what it was
it was to control the black population
seriously oh yeah the the nword project
yeah Margaret Sanger that [__] and you
know crazy thing is all of these studies
departments the women's studies they
literally hide history if you request
certain documents they'll like ask you
who you are they won't give it to you
yes yes because this is what they say
they say we're going to reite like we're
basically going to read history from the
like from the point of view of the
oppressed so what is what does that
switch it because now you're they don't
believe the writings of the women at the
time they don't believe any of the
historical evidence it's like no we're
going to put our spin on history and not
make it real history yeah and the
women's studies Department they'll like
hide Margaret sangers like racist rants
all of her racist [__] they just hide
it's it's it's it's crazy as [__] and
stuff like and then on top of that
there's this this whole like Ian this is
this is mixing the red pill in with the
Conspiracy Theory with like crypto but
like they've been I mean we know we all
know this [__] they've been trying to
control the global population for a
[__] long time now they and it's
really messed up they started with the
African-American community and let's
let's not even talk about all these
freaking vaccines I'm not talking about
the ones that happened recently I'm
talking about way back in the day that
they're infecting people they were
literally infecting people with like
tuberculosis and all this crazy ass crap
to get people sick to kill them off and
then I mean even the Germans the Germans
were using these these machines and
stuff on um the Jewish people as well as
EG Gypsies and people that they didn't
like so they would imagine like they
make their own Planned Parenthood you
would come in there they would have like
a basically a radiation machine kind of
set like this they would turn it on and
you would be standing in line and they
you couldn't have kids anymore and that
[__] is real the Germans did that so
there's some [__] up [__] 80% of
Planned Parenthood are in minority
neighborhoods why 80% still to this day
think about this okay we will cancel
Nike or whatever store for having racist
Roots but the black population would be
double today if it wasn't for Planned
Parenthood and so it's like they
literally said we're going to try to
control the black population and they're
doing it and nobody cares yet they'll
cancel Nike or whatever Corporation it
is for its racist founder racist Roots
but it's like someone that's committing
a genocide in front of our eyes they
don't care now I got to say this right
now right I've see this [__] they're
starting to do this with the Latino
population right now and I I put now I
I'll just say this right now they're
they're starting to like prop they're
for the first time they're starting to
prop up some of these Latino artists and
put them up and stuff and a lot I mean
who's the most popular one they propped
up recently is Bad Bunny and he's this
this dude this
no she's like she's black she's like I
don't know yeah she's mixing stuff but
she's like looking pretty
bad no makeup and stuff and like no hair
and everything like that and then now
she's trying to pretty herself up and
stuff but he no hate right but no we
like we have people like you know like
um I mean we were starting to have some
of these Latino artists come up and
stuff and they're being they're like
it's almost going like humiliation
rituals and stuff a half these dudes are
like dressing in the music videos in
ladies clothes and this is like and this
is the people the like Bad Bunny and
stuff like like I I actually like Bad
Bunny when he started off and then as
soon as he started popping they put him
in dresses he starts wearing [__]
like colored [__] nails and stuff
it's just and like what are they trying
to do are starting to destroy the family
structure of Latino families and stuff
we have like a machismo culture where
the man the man's the bread winner we
have the woman's supposed to stay at
home we supposed to have a bunch of kids
and they're coming after this cuz what
we're like 30% of the [__] population
now we're heading for 50 and they're
like oh we need to slow this [__]
down and how do they do it women cuz
we're
idiots we're dummies it's bad buddies
wearing dresses not now but but he's
yeah he sometimes weird you know was a
big red pill for me I was like oh my God
part of the depopulation agenda was
women's sports when I started looking
into women's sports yeah because it
makes you why do you think we got all
these dkes that are like yeah yeah why
do we got all these like lesbian chicks
in the
WNBA in the women's soccer why do we
have these women that because working
out like men raises our
testosterone it does and it makes you
more masculine and then I look at is
that because of competition I don't know
why exactly I just talked to like a
hormone doctor and he like I guess women
are only supposed to work out like two
weeks out of the month or some like
there's some I don't I don't understand
I don't really understand it I just was
talking to this hormone doctor and he
said yeah and the crazy thing is if you
um a lot of people that are trans the
issue is actually their hormones and he
would detransition people like people
like basically he would check out a girl
like come in and say she thought she was
a d transition yeah like she thought she
wanted to change genders and it turns
out she just had high testosterone or
low testosterone for males so it's part
of it and like the thing about
volleyball is it's very much very
feminist and a lot of feminists like run
all of this stuff and so it's like and I
was thinking about this I'm like
literally like the the volleyball
pipeline is like you play until you're
30 35 and then you know half and make no
money right and you make no money yeah
and I was thinking like how silly is it
I'm like I spent my early 20s chasing a
career that makes Zer doar that's like
it's like men would never no and it was
a lot of fun and I loved it but it's
like weird looking back it's like
literally travel volleyball you're gone
two weeks a month you spend like two I
spent two to four hours a day like
working out since I was like 12 years
old and yeah and so I was just thinking
about it and I'm like it's and it's all
by like lesbians that run a lot of this
stuff and like yeah and then and then
it's like your family is the team
it's not your actual family now soccer
is getting quite big now isn't it women
soccer starting to make some money
apparently yeah not really no I mean I
would guarantee I would be really
surprised if they don't operate at a
loss the only way I see women's sports
making money is if they do it off of
social media and like have the girls be
like social media influencers get some
drama in there clout and stuff and they
got VI yeah or maybe you know sexuality
like that's the a super hot athlete and
uh she gets a there's there's a one girl
like a gymnast yeah she's really cute
and then she gets a lot of stick because
it's like oh she people only like her
cuz she's
hot no but it's like but it's like when
you think about it that whole industry
it's like an industry that's subsidized
meaning like the majority of it operates
at a loss like we don't have the demand
for it and it really just makes us in
Dem man like that's and it's not even
taking nothing from like Serena Williams
cuz she's like the most dominant like
basically person in like in women's
tennis but even she admits she will get
destroyed by a a top 300 guy and she has
the guy was hung over the guy was hung
over no he was he was hung over people
were not shocked that he lost people are
shocked that he he scored a point on her
like that she scored a point on him so
it was that's the kind of stuff we're
talking about but like Serena I don't
give no shakes or Serena she actually
was like she admitted it and stuff she's
like oh yeah I get just and stuff what
was what was that guy from the 70s again
that tennis player like uh he was always
kind of like controversial or whatever
Mack Andro exactly I I mean he was
getting a lot of [__] for saying that uh
like yeah Serena if she were to play a
man right she would she would probably
have a lot of trouble she would lose
she's even admitted that before and then
they you know there's a clip of
basically Serena saying exactly that
yeah and then on a talk show on a talk
and then they crucify him for it you
know and it's just like people want to
live in a fantasy land you know it's
like La well women want to live in LA
and that's like what it is but isn't
there a conflict between the feminists
isn't there a conflict between the
feminists and the trans people coming
into the the sport though cuz wouldn't
the feminist work say well hang on a
minute these people are coming into our
you know yeah I mean
we just did a tournament I I didn't
actually play in it but I went to watch
cuz I forgot to register in time but
yeah there was a bunch of [__] it
was like an all nations tourn oh yeah in
England there was an all nations
tournament and um for whatever reason
why does Brazil have so many trans
people they like it was like Brazil and
the Philippines I'm like what is going
on the music I'm telling you they're
using the music to to hit the Latino
Community I'm telling you ever SE gosh
yeah they are it's probably the probably
the surgery is quite cheap over there as
well if you fancy getting it done you
yeah you can get it but it's like the
music that is literally lyric that's
what they're doing it's it's really
strange [__] I mean I've talked about
this before in the past like the reason
that like we haven't been infected with
lesbians too much in at least in the
Mexican Community is because we we used
to have a a star it's really sad she got
killed by lesbian women and this Selena
Selena Selena like her her basically her
manager not her manager but her like her
fan club manager basically was stealing
money and promising hey um like Pro's
going to show up to this event and stuff
and then she was money from like you
know regular people and stuff like that
and then what happened is this lesbian
she was about to get fired she pulled a
gun she shot salana and she died right
well because um in the Mexican media
they they they played out this she was
this this angry lesbian chick or
something like the Latinos the Mexican
Latinos [__] hate lesbians so like we
saved ourselves one
cycle but I'm starting to see that
creeping up now because they're pushing
in Puerto Rico one of some of the
hottest two of the hottest songs were
basically made by these these basically
these lesbian chicks are all talking
about the you know the best kind of
chicks or the chicks you can kiss and
that this is like literally the lyrics
are blasting I you couldn't escape it I
Kissed a
Girl Like and we're banned sorry but
like yeah but that's what's going on
right is but they're pushing this crazy
that was in Puerto Rico I I can't
imagine what they're playing right now
in like Brazil right now it's got to be
something because there is a bunch of
them from bra Philippines was the worst
that was the most not Thailand no it was
the Philippine team they they that was
like I think four or five on the court
were dudes Dam damn yeah yeah did you
guys ever have a chance of beating or
they were just destroying you no they
weren't even they were like kind of like
it was kind of weird because if they did
something too masculine they'd like hold
back you could like see you know what I
mean they would they' hope yeah they
were clearly not the most athletic guys
you know what I mean
like so true
women I don't know but that was yeah and
you know it's crazy I was tweeting about
it and they pulled up a tweet where I
said um oh no the [__] have like
made it to England and like volleyball
England messaged me and basically like
said this is a transphobic tweet and I
was confused because I had a different
tweet that said I'm afraid of trans
people so I was like I don't know why
you'd pick that
one but but and it was crazy because
yeah I'm I'm supposed to get like a
disciplinary S I don't really care they
could kick me out but it's it's just
crazy because even like talking about it
we got now these wokies are trying to
tell me I can't complain right I mean me
they don't like freedom of speech yeah
they don't like freedom of speech
instead but I'm telling you the best
thing you can do right now is um in
major sports is BET on the males playing
in the female sports you make a fortune
I'm telling you right now it's there's
so much money what sports I mean it be
it would be mostly what like there's
soccer there's baseball there's actually
a lot of fighting Sports actually you're
having a lot of like these mixed martial
arts I haven't seen it in the UFC yeah
there's a there's a ton of women that
are getting their ass beat bad I'm
talking about like bloody like [__] up
and stuff like that there's a lot of
there's weird ones with track for some
reason track's another big one where you
have a lot of Mal coming swimming
swimming tournament my friend said she
like hurt her finger cuz the dude like
hit so hard really dang yeah she'll be
all right
but but yeah but there's like there's
stories of this stuff where like they
have some of these and I'm not trying to
make this whole stream about this but
like you had some of these you know
these uh some of these people come into
these events and there's some women that
been training their whole life and they
they've missed the opportunity to go to
the next level or to go to D1 or
something whatever the hell it is and
what what the [__] you know so sad
because we literally train like I can
even count like there was maybe like
three really important like moments in
my career that like I think I went to
the ncas twice I went to State once and
it's like we'll train our whole lives
like 12 15 years for like a couple
moments it's like you're taking away
like we barely we don't even get money
we like barely have anything you can't
give us yeah like what do you guys sell
girls got cookies and paper everything
no no it's usually like taken from from
the men it's usually subsidized like
most women's sports operates at a loss
I'd be I'd be really surprised if women
women's soccer off operates at a profit
I'd be surprised I just heard something
on the radio the other night they were
saying somebody from America was on a
briti station they were just saying oh
you know it's starting to pop off a
little bit but so I mean there are some
women that are pushing back though
aren't there like I think it was Sharon
Davis the British swimmer um she was
saying that there should be a separate
category for
transs you know um I don't even think we
should do
that watch a league of
that their own probably probably more
than women's
sports like watching a train wreck but
but but the whole thing about you know a
woman's training for entire life for
that that to do that event you know to
do that swimming event and then some dud
you know some you know a trans person
just you know beats her it's just not
yeah it's just not right is it you know
pretty [__] yeah it's it's I mean it's
I mean it's kind of a it's kind of a
crazy sort of thing man this how is it
how is it in the volleyball scene though
in the UK now is it is it just it's it's
just you
can't it's just accepted these are women
and this is that that's how it's
presenting well I don't know if there I
didn't notice any in like regular season
that was like an offseason tournament
okay and they were being really vague
with me when I was asking them about the
rules but from what I understand in
regular season they're not allowed as of
now um and some Pro like cuz it's it pro
it depends on the country I guess but in
off season they're allowed to play with
us oh okay um like in like fun
tournaments but I'm like I don't want to
I don't want to break my fingers for fun
like what the [__] like like I signed up
for a woman's tournament get them out of
here right now RZ now we can talk about
RZ right we can talk about the so I mean
just to go to the RZ and stuff like I
mean like so obviously you you've been
in these professional teams like what do
guys what what's the RZ or what's how
are guys picking up these girl these
sports girls or is I know you were
saying it's full of lesbians and stuff
like that and it's full but like what
what are guys trying to do and stuff to
pick these sports girls up I mean or are
they struggling really bad because I
know a lot of them are very very tall
depending on the sport of course um well
the lesbians are on basketball excited
basketball and volleyball volleyball
isn't too lesbian that's not too no like
there's byy chicks on volleyball but not
not straight up lesbians um I just say
athletes usually date each other um I
would say the majority of my team in
England is single and there's like three
chicks that dated basketball players
it's kind of how it goes got it um in
college yeah it was
mostly Sports people just dated each
other right just athletes
athletes okay cool Olympic Village
stories you know
yeah actually I interviewed a girl on
the show that like did that and she said
she had a boyfriend during like the
Olympics cuz she played basketball for
it right yeah she said she regretted
like not cheating on him
yeah yeah I was like wow we actually B
women I know it's just like we're so
silly we just like believe anything damn
that's crazy we just like do things I
don't know you guys you just go you you
guys just believe all these startups
yeah I don't know so um I guess just
kind of get back to all that stuff like
um I mean you know dang dude this this
conversation went kind of off everybody
else right there with that but it's but
it's an important thing to talk about
when because I mean this stuff's
happening and it's being propagated and
it's being pushed out by all these
powers that be and stuff like we got the
Central Bank digital currencies coming
out right now uh we're having the roll
out basically two weeks ago what
happened in Chicago they're going to
start testing into more cities i' I'd
say basically by October we have it more
or less online already and the UK is
going to fall as suit every other
country is the whole EU the whole EU is
coming out with their own Central Bank
digital currency for the the Euro and
stuff China's already got the leg
they've been they've been testing it
since the so I think social no the 20189
yeah they've been playing around with it
and stuff like that and then here's some
weird [__] with that so if you actually
went to those Winter Olympics where
where the Chinese were actually giving
out the the currency it had a timer on
it so hey Pearl you've got two Troy you
guys you guys have two weeks or or two
days to spend this money or it's gone
man and that's the [__] that's so scary
about this crap is that in the beginning
they're going to like we're like so okay
so we're we're kind of like right now
we're like we're China Light so whatever
so there's always this Coke and Pepsi
thing we're like whoever the two biggest
super are we're like revolving around
each other right so when the Russians
were like the big threat during the USSR
they were they were sting satellites up
in space so we started the [__] Mo
the Space Race well China has started
this this whole thing of basically this
kind of draconian sort of like
communistic like we control your money
now we're China Light On We're chining
light and the whole rest of the world's
following suit so what's going on right
now is like I mean if you even look at
Twitter we went to Twitter X I like Elon
Musk but Elon Musk is pro crypto but
he's what he's doing he's making Twitter
into
WeChat like if you see what's going on
we're basically converting all our apps
into basically Chinese versions of those
apps and we're not we're not even waking
up to that [__] because what's going to
happen is our you know our fed now thing
which have has a biometric scan on your
on your thumb prints and stuff so your
cards have like a chip in order for use
your card you have to put your thumb on
it about six months six months or less
yeah that shit's all coming out and
these are going to be on the big so
you're going on some of the really
high-end credit cards you're going to
have the thumb prints on it and then
eventually all the FED Now cards are
going to have the thumb prints on it and
that'll be in the next year or less
really easy to get that Ubi and stimy
check money you know yeah I mean easy
money I mean people like we were saying
right women like the only fans women
they want the lowest barrier to entry
just to get the easiest money possible
so it's just one of those things that's
just going to make Society even more
complacent you know what's crazy it's
like how much Dumber we're getting as a
society yeah you ever like listen to
people talk like like recordings from
like the N early like when they first
started I think 1920s it's really crazy
they're they're just so much smarter
good story yeah we're just getting like
Dum I I hope I'm helping all going to AI
anyways wait so so what do you do then
how do you avoid it I mean basically
can't avoid you can't aoid but you yeah
you can
opt what's the danger here though that
they're then going to say right so you
said this on a podcast you you were on
the dollar cost crypto podcast and you
said this so therefore you you know you
can't SP money it's basically I'm not
saying we're going to have a social
credit score but it's sort of like what
happened on Twitter when the lefties
controlled it is that all right pearl
you're talking a little too much [__]
right
now we'll start turning stuff what they
did to Andrew Tate that was a test
Andrew Tate but if I'll even go back
Alex Jones technically was the first one
that happened here it was a test they K
they what because of all the Sandy Hook
stuff that he was talking about and he
apologized for and he was I'm sorry I
was wrong about that one even before he
got in trouble right right then then
they canceled him took his bank accounts
did all this crazy [__] then they did
Andrew Tate same thing boom boom boom
boom boom and then there except he he
got big enough and he had so much social
media presence that like even the
Ukrainian government I not Ukrainian I'm
sorry UK yeah Ro Romania kind of backed
off a little bit but they still have him
under house arrest in the country
essentially but he's not house arrested
actually technically yeah he can just
roam around but he can't leave the
country and and this is and this is like
kind of the like all the crazy [__]
that's happening is that we're heading
towards like a somewhat a light social
credit system it's sort of like you know
the the permanent record like they that
permanent record is kind of being the
switch has been flipped on a little bit
and um this is why we're so crazy about
crypto because in crypto it's sort of
this [__] up [__] right now because
like the men men are so [__] beta
right now that all you need is three or
5% of the population to rise up and
[__] go but they're [__] doing
everything they can to run interceptions
to keep everyone [__] asleep because
if we if if men like men are one thing
one of the smartest [__] that like
Andrew tra ever said if men like they're
they're afraid of men getting together
you have a you have a room of just men
the government pays attention so if you
had a lot of men just say [__] the [__]
we ain't taking this and they all go to
Capitol Hill and they go to Washington
shit'll change over [__] night but
but this is about why we have to have
the we have to have the circus this
clown circus and this [__] bread and
these lines and the lions and trainers
we have to have all this distraction
Sunday Night Football what's going on
you know we have to have all this crap
because it keeps the [__] dodos
[__] sleeping the sheeple well then
at that time when it comes around
they're just going to say anybody who's
congregating is basically conf uh like
forming a conspiracy and right they're
Nazis or whatever ha speech you know BL
blah blah blah but all these you know
things to just shut people up right so
it's the opposite of free speech they
say oh yeah you can say anything you
want except for this isn't that because
it's fact checked and blah blah blah
blah blah there was a case in in England
actually recently I don't know if you
heard about it but Nigel farage who was
the politician behind brexit right
basically like the key bring leader for
brexit he got his bank account cancelled
by CS which is a big Private Bank in the
UK and it became this big Scandal
because he spoke out about it and he was
and they canceled him well apparently
there were different reasons but one of
the reasons was hisl iCal views we're
not in alignment with their terms and
conditions so but because he's quite a
big figure in the UK he spoke out about
it and it became this big Scandal and
you know there they're looking into it
now but it's it's it's very much in line
with what happened with with Tate and
with you know I mean imagine this
imagine this like like let's just say we
didn't have crypto and we just had this
right now what'll happen is if you start
to speak out Troy you I mean basically
we'd have to find a way to donate or
You' have to have a homie with you to
pay for stuff for you cuz you'd be
completely out of the system have to you
mean you basically go back to bartering
well then maybe the Amish had it figured
out I mean I've seen videos of Amish gr
like literally like like doing drifting
in their [__] cars sh [__] little
cors and Buggies well yeah but then
you're going to have like entire Sports
well you already have entire sports
stadiums that only take digital payments
they won't even take cash some stadiums
anymore right and so then you right now
there's laws that can uh basically say
cash can't get phased out it'll be
interesting to see if that starts
flipping and how much people actually
care cuz if people don't put up any form
of resistance just going to make it
easier so I'm going to go into some top
dork [__] right here this is top dork
[__] right here right the super dork is
we we we have to fight to keep do even
if even if even if eventually it becomes
outdated like why do we have physical
dollars it's really important another
thing too that they're trying to get rid
of the penny right the phys you know
just pennies right no one really uses
them anymore but the reason they're
important is because if you get rid of
the penny then what's the next one 5
cents so when they start increasing
prices they start increasing it by 5
cents at a time and if you get rid
imagine they get rid of all the they
keep quarters so that means what'll
happen is whatever the lowest Domin
nomination well that's the only thing we
can increase it by so we just do this so
what'll happen is if you get rid of the
penny and you get rid of the 5 cents and
the dimes and you just go to quarters
you'll start having prices start jumping
up crazy you're admitting that it's
worthless exactly it's a Dogecoin right
this [__] fictional coin that Elon
mus kind of Pumped up and stuff right
was worth fractions of pennies is at the
peak 81 cents so you're saying a a [__]
I mean yeah y shout to Elon but like but
like if you're you're saying some this
fake little meme coin that literally
does nothing it's just a mem coin was
worth almost as much as a [__]
dollar with infinite inflation shout to
L but like infinite inflation and this
is the [__] that's so scary and then on
top of that so so they're going to give
this Wick money that's I'm going to call
it it's going to be Wick money right
they're going to give these these things
here's $1 th here's thousand thousand
thousand everyone has a th right and
then what'll happen is they'll start
phasing dollars out and then eventually
what is gonna what's going to happen
here is Pearl you can't buy guns you
can't buy this you can't buy that you
can't buy this and then you can't
anymore so the reason why cryp they're
trying to keep because crypto now is
like I can always pay for stuff in
ethereum yeah or Bitcoin forever and
this is why they're so crazy about
stable coins they're so [__] crazy
about we had PayPal come with a stable
coin and and people I I don't know why
didn't people didn't realize this you
know tether could freeze your [__] you
know [__] usdc conf freeze or stuff
people looked into the source code on
the PayPal U they should call it PP USD
but py USD but um this coin is like
running on the oldest language like of
like of like solidity already which is
you know they probably should have done
have done that but they can freeze
everything but it works almost the same
as as usdc but the reason people are
freaking out about PayPal it's because
PayPal are a bunch of [__]
like a lot of the times they hold your
account a lot like imagine if you make
$100,000 in revenue on PayPal hey you're
making too much money they'll hold 10
15,000 of it and just won't give it back
to you for weeks what they're doing just
holding your [__] money and giving
themselves a [__] loan and they do
this to thousands of
businesses so imagine you make 1,00
bucks sorry I'm holding 500 of it I've
have so many people that started these
PayPal accounts or these Commerce
accounts and they're holding tons of
people's cash because this is how they
float themselves because they take your
money they do temporary T I mean this is
sort D I know they take they take the
stuff they either lending it to
themselves illegally or what they're do
they grab your cash do like a one week
or a three 3 we sort of bond and stuff
make a little bit of money in your money
give it back to you are they operating
at a loss then it yeah they have but
like they must be but like they're they
literally can they now have a policy
within their they they say if they do
not like what you have to say they can
just take all your [__] money that
they that you have in there I use PayPal
a lot Pearl like drain it every time you
get cash in there drain it back yeah
PayPal is is has been tricky for a lot
for a lot of people yeah but my friend
has got there's a an account with
another online Bank in the UK and again
I mean they just held $100,000 yeah you
know I mean just it's scary what do I'm
just
kidding he's like them
boys why can't we
talk but but yeah this is like this is
like the progression of stuff we're
seeing right now and like I sort of like
I sometimes I feel disae but this is why
I would be push crypto so hard is
because we can get I mean it's we're
entering a golden cage like the smart
one of us the Millennials some of the
extras some of the zoom the older zomers
are going to get crypto in they make
they're make a lot of cash and then
we're going to be able to float around
how we like but a lot of people they're
going to be the slave class and I just
hope that you know over time we kick
some of these Boomers out and we and we
put some decent laws because if you look
at what happened during the uh Tech boom
back in like you know 1996 all the way
to 2000 um if if you really look at what
happened there they didn't stifle that
Innovation they they did laws if you
like it wasn't until what 2004 2006 that
that Amazon started paying sales tax on
the [__] internet wouldn't that be
why the [__] are we even getting tax on
crypto anyway okay I can understand
admit you have it cool or or there
should be like an exit tax all right you
can buy you can sell into stable coins
but the moment you sense your bank
account okay that's fair game tax air we
don't have these [__] laws instead
they're [__] stifling in Innovation
the best crypto companies on this
[__] planet or all moving out like
you can't start a [__] crypto company
as an American it's it's like it's
basically [__] illegal unless you
have a ton of they're going to just come
after you you can start it they'll let
you go for a while right and then
they're going to be like and you're done
I got really mad right now I'm getting
I'm getting really irritated with this
[__] because like I care so much about
America and I care about a lot of other
countri because it's not it's not the
people that are evil it's the [__]
governments and it's the [__] these
small groups of Elites that are pushing
the governments are giving them all the
money to do all this evil [__] and
[Applause]
women yeah
when oh yeah got put out the shirt yeah
there we go there we
go
that way no for real I really think
women were the biggest tool that they've
used they us yes I because it's like
they just realize they're like oh [__]
women are idiots we can just put
anything in their ear and they'll just
believe it like and it's so funny doing
this show I just hear the same arguments
like the men or the abusers like why
does every woman think that like I'm in
a you know a room full of guys you guys
haven't tried to abuse me
once like it's like and so I just you
know I hear how we just like repeat
things and just like the propaganda and
how well it works on us I'm like they
literally just gave us the vote so they
could use us feel like a cheap [__] you
know what I mean it's like literally
they they gave us the vote so they could
just get the propaganda on the radio and
all that [__] so they could do whatever
they wanted to the society and they but
they use everybody they use sure they're
us they're weaponizing women against men
right now to keep everyone distracted
but every but they've also like
minorities too yeah minority but but
it's it's everybody it's like like we we
went from like slavery where we're no
there's no longer any slaves but there's
e we're economic slaves we're working
and stuff so they they all right we'll
let the we'll let the slaves because
they still think of almost everybody
even everyone in this room they think
we're all still slaves they really just
we're just oh these are just my tax
cattle surf surfs and stuff like I mean
this is why a mortgage is like why is it
why is your when you buy a house it's
called a mortgage because it's going to
take you until you [__] die to pay
that [__] off m